I saw crooks man like i said before me
you know i saw cross bottom line you
know you can't trust none of these guys
to get my vote I don't know baby that'll
be really tough you know like after the
whole Obama he didn't do nothing nothing
for like you know the urban communities
the minority I personally think that
Hillary Clinton is essentially Obama 2.0
it's a continuation of the Obama
policies which did not work Obama did
not bring change he was enabled to her I
like Hillary you know cuz I feel like
you know she has understanding of what's
going on she's been here I honestly
think that Bernie Sanders is the best
candidate for Harlem african-american
women are graduating at a higher rates
than then you know a lot of other
cultures so I think that free free
college education would really bring
through to a lot of people here in
Harlem and be really important for them
I think dungeon with um
I